Speaker 1: So we are going to talk on the bonus
show today about how terribly Donald Trump's
social media platform, truth social is doing.
Speaker 2: Truth central.
Speaker 1: Yes, truth central. As some people know
it. Donald Trump yesterday spent a bunch of time
on truth, social, just flipping out. And
you can tell this guy is panicking. This
guy realizes the walls are closing in around him.
The lawyers he picked from just seeing them on TV
don't seem to be representing him in the most
coherent and competent way. And Donald Trump
with another one of these multi post
tirades that used to be reserved for Twitter
until Trump was banned. Trump kicking it off
with the now emblematic all caps witch hunt
with three exclamation points. You know, I
actually respect three exclamation points when
I see two. It's a little weird. But, you know, if
you want to do one exclamation point or three, I
can get behind that. So at least Trump with three
exclamation points. Then Trump posting, quote,
When are the great agents and others in the FBI
going to say, we aren't going to take it anymore,
much as they did when James Comey read off a
list of all of crooked Hillary Clinton's crimes,
only to say that no reasonable prosecutor would
prosecute the wonderful people of the FBI went
absolutely nuts. So Comey had to backtrack and do
a fake investigation in order to keep them at bay.
The end result We won in 2016 and we did much
better in 2020, but now the left has lost their
minds. That is a wild, wild assertion. It's
gobbledygook. It's a verbal inkblot. Well,
it's I guess it's a written one. That doesn't
make any sense. And Trump just not relenting,
continuing with, quote, The raid on my home,
Mar a Lago is one of the most egregious assaults
on democracy in the history of our capital C
country, which is, by the way, going to places
in a very bad way it has never seen
before. And then lastly, back to all caps,
invasion of privacy. And again, this could be
referring to anything. This could be referring to
the raid on Mar a Lago itself. This could be
referring to what's in the affidavit. I mean,
with Donald Trump, you never really know. This
is a very scared but also incompetent, delusional
and narcissistic individual. And what some are
now suggesting is that when you take remember,
Trump never apologizes. Trump never thinks he did
anything wrong. He never takes responsibility.
That's been the theme typical of narcissists.
What some are now starting to speculate
is that this it's it's always been unhinged,
but there's something uniquely unhinged about
about this, that Trump now is starting to be
the authoritarian dictator, wannabe narcissist
who is starting to believe the walls may be
closing in around me. And one of the difficulties
when such people start to believe that is
that I hate to use this analogy because
I'm not literally comparing people to animals, but
when cornered animals realize they're cornered,
sometimes they start to behave in ways that are
extremely out of character, unpredictable, erratic
and dangerous. And when you take a true narcissist
who never apologizes, never admits that he's
done anything wrong and believes he's always he
believes he's so much smarter than everybody else
that if you just let him talk to them, he'll talk
his way out of an indictment and investigation,
whatever. When they start to think, Wow, I really
may be screwed here, all bets are off about what
they might be willing to do, and we may well
be getting to that spot with Donald Trump.
The next two months are going to be nuts. Next two
months are going to be truly, truly nuts. We're
going to take a very quick break. Make sure you're
following us on Facebook, Facebook.com slash David
Pakman show. And remember that Wednesday, this
Wednesday, August 31st at 6 p.m. Eastern, we will
be doing the members only townhall. If you'd like
to participate. Sign up at join pacman dot com.